adrian hauser makes his first start
since august the third rock and he was
really good in that appearance we'll see
what he brewers get out of him here this
afternoon the batter has won soto now
with a runner aboard and one man out
ground ball to short this could be two
adamus the second one on to first that
is a double flow
taylor made
it'll end up going six five three
brewers coming up
colton wong will lead things off
swinging a drive to right deep warning
track get up get out of here
he just put the crew on top
with a lead off home run
what a series for colton wong leadoff
home run
three rockets to start the game
brewers coming out swinging like the
nats did yesterday and in hitting right
fielder avicial garcia coming up
fastball no 80 changeup
got it up and away for the strikeout
that's the first out of the inning now
if you get a ground ball you can get out
of the inning
2-0
center cut there's a ground ball at
somebody key boom a step to the bag
boy what a throw over to the first base
side an absolute missile 5-3 on the
double play luis orios
will lean things off
down the left-field line hernandez gives
it a ride falls in front of him
big turn around first and putting on the
brakes ureas it's a lead off single hit
number four for the crew
brings up manny pina
driven to left hernandez another shot
falls in front of him
manny pina stays hot
second and third for colton wong
great pitch
made it look like a strike for a moment
that got in the cave
see if they can take advantage with two
outs trailing one to nothing it'll be
lane thomas
fastball up on 02 and he's got another
opposite field head
to third riley adams
what a series for lane thomas that's his
fifth hit
and he's been on base eight times
nationals a scoring opportunity here in
the top of the third
on the move thomas bald gets away and
coming home
is riley adams
ball runner fielder arriving at the same
time and lane thomas ends up at third
after a steal and he went feet first it
looked like the ball might have hit him
in the helmet i think it did it did
a little ricochet off the dome and he
pops up gets to third base
riley adam scores
i hear his bell at the plate
belt chops one left side
long run
safe is the call if he throws it once he
fields it he's got josh bell but josh
smelling a hit hustling all the way
sneaky fast with those long strides
beats it out arielle hernandez digs in
yada yall hit into a double play his
first time up
on a pitch away
right through the infield
over to third
josh bell some good oppo going on for
yadiel hernandez whether in the air or
on the ground a little bit of trouble to
try to navigate here for strickland
and here's the one too swinging a miss
he struck him out with a fastball in 94.
and that is her big strikeout for hunter
strickland a two away and riley adams is
the batter
two two coming back
struck him out with a breaking ball
strickland comes in strikes out ki boom
strikes out adam's
rally over for washington
so back-to-back walks now and the
brewers have first and second with two
outs for colton long
down the right field line
extra bases for colton wong
pina's in
here comes jbj he's in to third long
to run triple it's all colton wong here
this afternoon
here's that pitch
maybe up a little bit but colton wong
able to center on it we just showed you
the graphic hitting 320 against lefties
that's going to go up
all the way in the corner and the two
walks with two outs come around to score
a big day for lane thomas again
walk base hits steal
look at this guy hooking one all the way
to the wall we'll keep an eye on garcia
and lane thomas
has been a revelation for the gnats here
base runners against ashby here in the
top of the fifth
breaking ball he went around
quite the sequence right there for aaron
ashby against the veteran of cd's
escobar
now bell he's walked and reached on an
infield single
chopper to short adamus
beats soto to the bag and ashby
gets out of the bases loading jam
starting with yadiel hernandez
waves at that breaking ball got it two
times in a row
ashby with another strikeout his third
ashby looking for a quick and easy
inning
3-2 to adams
struck him out
two strikeouts in a flawless sixth
inning for aaron ashby on the heels of
yesterday's ugly one hit batter in two
walks
and the bases are loaded for christian
yelich and all he did yesterday was
become the 12th different player to hit
a grand slam against the nationals this
season
one two
swinging a bouncer first base fair ball
step on first for one throw home it's
wide one run is in here comes wong he
scores
to third in time and safe as adamus josh
bell got the ground ball he tagged first
base for an out and it was a tag play at
home plate
and air mail is the throw
not even close all the way to the screen
cole wong never slows down and another
run in
five to one brewers
credit christian yelts with an rbi
home long scores on the e3
three balls two strikes two men around
second and third
the 3-2
ground ball sharply hit
diving stab throw to first wow what a
play by garcia
this took two runs off the board and
more importantly eduardo escobar
was a little slow as he hit that first
base bag the brewers are going to check
on escobar that does not look good
so a man aboard now for lorenzo kane
deep into left center field way back
lorenzo kane
a two-run blast it's 7-1 brewers
lorenzo kane joins the hit parade boy
look at that pitch
talk about barreling it up
getting it on the sweet spot and the
back leg finish for low kane i love when
he does that the abi garcia coming up
and the pitch to him swinging and a
drive to sutter and deep get up
get up it is off the wall
to third is yellets
to second is garcia with a double
and the brewers are in business again
here is luis aureus standing in
front door in the breaking ball
double play
ki boom grabbed it yelich couldn't get
back
two down nice play
then he dives for the bag doubles up
yelling so two down just like that on a
nice play by carter kiku
carter just had a good defensive inning
had a hand in all three outs
ooh he launches one to left
c
u
later
carter kibum
fourth of the year ants are on the board
for the first time since the third
inning make a great play lead off the
ending with the tater i always say
four home runs on the season
that was 4 14. he got out of here in a
hurry
lane thomas gets one more a b on what's
been a fabulous weekend for him owen two
and the back door breaking ball deep
short high throw
and that one ends up hitting the padding
on the side and coming around to score
as adams
josh hader
on to finish this one off hopefully for
the brewers
ground ball to short uris feeds a
domestic ball game over hater another
save and another series win for the crew
you